>>> IN OUR POLITICS LEAD, THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE HAS INFORMED
11 OFFICIALS WHO HAD BEEN
APPOINTED TO MILITARY SERVICE
ACADEMY BOARDS BY FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO RESIGN OR
THEY WILL BE FIRED, A SOURCE
SAYS THAT THOSE TOLD TO RESIGN
INCLUDE PROMINENT OFFICIALS.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY JEN
PSAKI ANSWERED QUESTIONS THIS
AFTERNOON ABOUT WHETHER
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS POLITICIZING
THE ISSUE.
>> I WILL LET OTHERS EVALUATE
WHETHER THEY THINK KELLYANNE
CONWAY AND SEAN SPICER AND
OTHERS WERE QUALIFIED OR NOT
POLITICAL TO SERVE ON THESE
BOARDS.
BUT THE PRESIDENT'S
QUALIFICATION REQUIREMENTS ARE
NOT YOUR PARTY REGISTRATION.
THEY ARE WHETHER YOU'RE
QUALIFIED TO SERVE AND WHETHER
YOU ARE ALIGNED WITH THE VALUES
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION.
>> KELLYANNE CONWAY JUST
RESPONDED ON TWITTER WITH A COPY
OF THE LETTER SHE SENT BACK TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN, WHICH
CONCLUDES, I AM NOT RESIGNING,
BUT YOU SHOULD.
LET'S DISCUSS.
PSAKI WAS RESPONDING TO YOUR
QUESTION THERE.
IT'S NOT JUST POLITICAL FIGURES
LIKE KELLYANNE CONWAY AND SEAN
SPICER THAT WERE FIRED FROM
THESE BOARDS.
IT INCLUDES DAVID URBAN WHO USED
TO BE A COMMENTATOR HERE.
HE WENT TO WEST POINT.
H.R. McMASTER.
ON SATURDAY HE'S GOING TO GET
THEIR HIGHEST ALUMNI ASSOCIATION
AWARD FOR GRADUATES.
SO THERE ARE SOME INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE A CLAIM TO THESE
POSITIONS WHO WERE JUST FIRED.
>> RIGHT.
AND THE POINT THAT JEN WAS
MAKING TO OUR QUESTIONS EARLIER
TODAY IS THAT THESE ARE
PRESIDENTIAL APPOINTEES.
SO OF COURSE THEY SERVE AT THE
PLEASURE OF THE PRESIDENT WHO IS
IN OFFICE.
AND SHE SAID -- SHE WANTED
APPOINTIES TO THE BOARD THAT
WOULD BETTER REFLECT THE
PRESIDENT'S VALUES.
TRADITIONALLY THESE BOARDS ARE
LARGELY ADVISORY AND CEREMONIAL.
A LOT OF THEM ARE THREE-YEAR
TERMS AND THEY GO ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION.
SO IT WAS AN INTERESTING MOVE BY
THE ADMINISTRATION TO DO THIS.
THE FORMER TRUMP OFFICIALS FIGHT
THIS?
KELLYANNE CONWAY'S LETTER SEEMED
TO THINK THAT SHE WAS GOING TO
PUSH THIS ON A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER.
>> RIGHT.
AND IT WASN'T EXACTLY A LETTER
THAT WAS DEMONSTRATING THAT SHE
WAS CAPABLE OF DOING A JOB IN A
NONPARTISAN WAY.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU BECAUSE THESE
TERMS FROM THESE BOARD MEMBERS
ARE STAGGERED.
THERE WERE PEOPLE FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ON THE BOARDS
WHEN TRUMP STARTED WHO WERE NOT
FIRED WHO ARE STILL THERE.
ONE OF THE FIRED BOARD OF
VISITORS APPOINTEES MEGHAN MOBBS
WROTE, PRESIDENT BIDEN RAN ON A
SUPPOSED PLATFORM OF UNITY BUT
HIS ACTIONS SPEAK DIRECTLY TO
THE CONTRARY.
WOULD KEEPING SOME OF THE PEOPLE
ON THE COMMITTEE -- ON THESE
BOARDS, WOULDN'T THAT BE MORE IN
KEEPING WITH WHAT BIDEN PROMISED
HE WOULD DO?
>> MAYBE.
BUT WE TALK ABOUT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AS IF THESE WERE
THE BUSH PEOPLE OR THEY WERE THE
REAGAN PEOPLE.
THEY WAS NOT LIKE A NORMAL
SITUATION.
WE HAD A PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WHO WAS DOING REALLY
IRREGULAR THINGS.
HE HAD A HOTEL THAT FOREIGN
LEADERS WERE STAYING AT TO TRY
TO PUT MONEY IN HIS POCKET, BY
OUR REPORTS.
AND HE GOT AWAY WITH THAT.
THEY PUT A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
ON THE COURT IN THE LAST YEAR OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AFTER DENYING
BARACK OBAMA TO DO THE VERY SAME
THING.
I THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS
IN THE TOTALITY OF WHAT HAS
HAPPENED WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND RECOGNIZE
THIS IS NOT NORMAL AND WE
SHOULDN'T PRETEND LIKE THE TRUMP
TIME WAS NORMAL.
>> THAT JUST SEEMS LIKE THE
RACHET EFFECT, WHICH IS WHAT WE
STRIVE TO PREVENT I THINK IF
WE'RE TRYING TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER.
IN ADDITION I FEEL IT TAKES A
REAL BRAIN FOR US TO LOOK AT
AFGHANISTAN AND BE, LIKE, THE
MILITARY NEEDS A SHAKEUP AND I
KNOW WHERE I'M GOING TO DO IT.
MEDICINE EAGAN MOBBS, JUST TO
NAME ONE, IS A YOUNG FEMALE
AFGHANISTAN VET ON THE BOARD OF
WEST POINT.
HER VIEWPOINT IS IMPORTANT AND
THE FACT THAT THESE PEOPLE CAN
WORK IN COMITY AND HAVE FOR
YEARS AND IS A BOONE TO THE
MILITARY.
>> I REMEMBER DURING THE
TRANSITION I WAS DOING A STORY
ON WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH WOULD
BE TO THE DIFFERENT CABINET
AGENCIES AND LOOKING AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
WHICH WAS THAT WAS SO MOLDED BY
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TO
FOCUS ON THE MORE AGGRESSIVE
IMMIGRATION POLICIES.
ONE TRANSITION, WHAT ABOUT
CAREER OFFICIALS THAT WERE HERE
FOR MULTIPLE ADMINISTRATIONS,
NOT JUST TRUMP BUT ALSO THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION?
OR JUST ANYBODY THAT WORKED FOR
TRUMP AND WAS INVOLVED IN THESE
POLICIES.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER KEEPING ANY
OF THEM?
AND THIS PERSON SAID THEY ARE
POISONED AT THIS POINT, WE'RE
MOVING ON FROM THOSE FOLKS.
NOW, THAT IS FOR POSITIONS WHERE
YOU'RE INSTRUMENTAL IN
IMMIGRATION POLICIES, BORDER
POLICIES.
THIS IS DIFFERENT.
THESE ARE, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BOARDS, AND AS WAS JUST STATED
SOME OF THOSE SYMBOLIC OF A
CERTAIN KIND OF BIPARTISANSHIP
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS TOUTED AS
WELL.
>> SENATE MAJORITY LEADER CHUCK
SCHUMER SAYING THEY'RE MOVING
FULL STEAM AHEAD WHEN IT COMES
TO THIS $3.5 TRILLION BUDGET
PACKAGE DESPITE REQUESTS FROM A
PAUSE FROM SENATOR MANCHIN.
WHO HAS THE POWER RIGHT NOW IN
THESE NEGOTIATIONS?
WE HAVE BOTH AOC AND JOE MANCHIN
AND CHUCK SCHUMER AND NANCY
PELOSI.
I CAN'T TELL WHO HAS THE
LEVERAGE.
>> RIGHT.
WELL, YOU'VE GOT SENATOR MANCHIN
WITH HIS RECENT COMMENTS.
YOU'VE GOT PELOSI WHO HAS SAID
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO TRY AND
BRING A VOTE ON INFRASTRUCTURE
BY SEPTEMBER 27th.
HOWEVER, IS THAT GOING TO COME
TO FRUITION NOW WITH MEMBERS OF
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE
ALSO FOCUSING ON RECONCILIATION?
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO WE DID SOME
REPORTING JONATHAN WISE MAN
WHERE WE SAID THE PRESIDENT HAS
CLEARLY SHOWED THAT HE CAN WORK
WITH SOME REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS.
BUT THIS IS THE REAL TEST OF
ACTUALLY CAN YOU UNIFY THOSE
WITHIN YOUR OWN PARTY.
>> RIGHT.
CAN HE WORK WITH THE PROGRESS
REPRESENTATIVES?
TAKE A LISTEN TO AOC.
>> I AS WELL AS MANY, MANY
MEMBERS OF THE PROGRESSIVE
CAUCUS SIMPLY WILL NOT VOTE FOR
SENATOR MANCHIN'S INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL UNLESS IT IS TIED TOGETHER
WITH THE BUILD BACK BETTER ACT
SO THAT WE HAVE AN
ALL-OF-THE-ABOVE APPROACH.
SO THAT WE AREN'T SAYING IT'S
EITHER YOUR BILL OR OUR BILL,
BUT THAT BOTH OF THESE BILLS
MUST MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER OR
NEITHER WILL.
>> IS THERE A PATH FORWARD HERE?
>> DEMOCRATIC LEADERS ARE TRYING
TO FIND A PATH FORWARD.
I THINK THE POWER REALLY SHIFTS
BACK AND FORTH DEPENDING ON
WHERE THINGS ARE.
AND I THINK LIBERALS HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY FRUSTRATED,
ESPECIALLY IN THE HOUSE BUT ALSO
IN THE SENATE AS WELL THAT SO
MUCH OF THE FOCUS HAS BEEN ON
THE MANCHINS OR THE SINEMAS OF
THE WORLD.
WE HAVE A VOTE AND WE HAVE A SAY
IN THIS MATTER, TOO.
A LOT OF THE HANGUPS ARE
PROCEDURAL, BUT THERE ARE DEEP
POLICY DIVISIONS TOO THAT WE
CAN'T -- WE ALSO HAVE TO FOCUS
ON HERE.
ONE IS ON HEALTHCARE, HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO, FOR EXAMPLE,
EXPAND MEDICARE BENEFITS VERSUS
SHORING UP OBAMACARE, AND DO YOU
HAVE THE MONEY TO DO THAT?
HOW HIGH DOES THE CORPORATE TAX
RATE GO?
REPUBLICANS WOULD CALL
ADISARRAY.
DEMOCRATS MIGHT CALL IT
DYNAMISM.
>> AND OF COURSE THERE ARE THE
19 SENATE REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY'RE GETTING PRESSURE FROM
THE MAGA SIDE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY TO NOT VOTE FOR THAT EVEN
THOUGH THEY SUPPORTED IT.
>> AND I THINK THE QUESTION WITH
THE POWER CENTER IS WHETHER
PROGRESSIVES ARE ACTUALLY
WILLING TO TORPEDO SOMETHING
WITH THAT SWEET, SWEET TRILLION
AT THE END OF IT EVEN IF IT'S 1
TRILLION.
THERE'S A TELLING QUOTE FROM
PELOSI WHERE SHE SAID, SO WE
HAVE RECONCILIATION
INFRASTRUCTURE CR, AND SOMEWHERE
IN THERE WE'LL DO THE DEBT
CEILING.
AND THE U.S. CONGRESS IS TELLING
YOU THAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO
MOST OF THIS DURING SEPTEMBER.
IT'S SEPTEMBER 8th.
GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
GET TO KISSING MANCHIN'S PINKY
RING AND MOVE ON.
>> I LOVE PELOSI WHEN THEY ASKED
HER THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
NUMBER.
SHE BASICALLY SAID, I SAID WHAT
I SAID, $3.5 TRILLION.
THE ONE ROAD IS PASS SOMETHING
AND GIVE PEOPLE SOMETHING TO RUN
ON AND TALK ABOUT OR OBLIVION.
IF THEY DON'T PASS ANYTHING,
2022 IS A WRAP.
THERE'S NOTHING FOR THEM TO RUN
ON ANYMORE.
SO THEY'VE GOT TO PASS
SOMETHING, I THINK EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS